next generation materialien bis auf
drogen genau so habt ihr einen nano
partikel noch nie gewählt jetzt wacklig
5 1 fiction herzlich willkommen eine
acht nanometer große eisenplatten
regierung wurde bis auf das letzte ab
analysiert die forscher im fachmagazin
nature berichten ist es erstmals
gelungen ein dreidimensionales gerücht
von circa 23.000 atomen inklusive deren
chemischen eigenschaften zu konstruieren
privat zum ersten mal können wir
einzelne atome und die chemische
zusammensetzung in drei dimensionen
sehen noch niemals zuvor wurde eine
solche dreidimensionale strukturelle
komplexität in so genau im detail
sichtbar gemacht das verständnis der
dreidimensionalen strukturen solcher
kauder oberflächen ist eine große
herausforderung in der materialforschung
berichtet die anweisung von der
university of california in los angeles
was wir hier sind genau 6269 eisen und
16 1727 platin atome jede einzelne
position der atome und der atomfreien
region konnte exakt bestimmt werden
wozu soll das gut sein wenn die forscher
wissen wie sich atome anordnen und dann
verhalten können rückschlüsse auf das
wachstum eines nano partikel und dessen
eigenschaften wie zum beispiel
magnetismus geschlossen werden
bei der auswertung ihrer arbeit stießen
die experten tatsächlich auf
auffälligkeiten einige atom anordnung
zeichneten sich in einem von ihnen
erzeugten magnetfeld von den anderen ab
peter erzählt vom lawrence berkeley
national laboratory zufolge können die
forscher künftig helfen das wachstum
solcher einem platin partikel so zu
steuern dass sie bessere magnet
eigenschaften bekommt das heißt wenn wir
wirklich in der lage sind die position
einzelner atome in materialien zu
bestimmen können wir diese viel
effizienter gestalten in diesem fall
könnten festplatten mit optimierten
eigenschaften produziert werden oder es
könnten zum beispiel batterien und akkus
viel mehr energie speichern sie
schneller abgeben und wieder aufnehmen
und so weiter steht uns also ein
zeitalter der nexgen materialien also
von next generation materialien bevor
möglich wäre es nach max anklingen auch
die technologien der wehr ihr raumschiff
enterprise mehr dazu hier im video und
damit ihr kein video mehr verpasst
einmal auch hier auf das auge klicken
und dann noch auf die glocke das ist
hier ganz unkompliziert bei youtube oder
glaubt ihr
wenn wir immer bessere materialien
bekommen wie wird unsere zukunft
aussehen
ich bin auf eure ideen gespannt und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran